ein kleinbus voller kinder kriegskinder
aus der ost ukraine
sie fliehen vor granaten bomben vor dem
tod die psychologin katharina shooter
nova bringt sie in sicherheit 1000
kilometer richtung westen in der nacht
gab es angriffe der russischen
streitkräfte auf hf der schreck sitzt
tief bei katja und den anderen
wir haben geschlafen hat im schlaf habe
ich explosionen gehört und dachte mir
das kann doch nicht sein wir sind doch
den haag hiess dann wache ich auf und
verstehe das ist wirklich wahr ein junge
hat angefangen vor angst zu zittern die
ganze matratze zitterte mit so groß
angst hat er
drei tage vorher am 21 februar
psychologin katharina shooter nova an
der front in den umkämpften dörfern im
don was schon vor dem einmarsch der
russen steht dort wo bis k schwer unter
beschuss die menschen hier geschockt
eine mörsergranate eingeschlagen
die kinder im kriegsgebiet sind der
gewalt den krieg schutzlos ausgeliefert
katharina therapiert sie treffen im
jugendclub
mein ziel ist es für die kinder etwas
sicherheit zu simulieren eine gemütliche
atmosphäre zu schaffen und zu reden denn
die erwachsenen hier sprechen mit ihnen
nicht über den krieg zwei kinder aus der
gruppe haben heute gar nichts gegessen
ein mädchen aus der gruppe sagte sie
kann nicht essen mädels wer von euch
möchte eine cola katharina sucht die
gespräche die kinder sollen erzählen was
sie bewegt
etwa fünf meter weg geflogen
besonders große angst habe ich davor
dass ein splitter ins zimmer fliegt mir
in den kopf frei fliegt um mich tötet
das wäre schrecklich
ihr euch umarmt und weint so könnt ihr
ganz gut diesen stress abbauen
sofort alle runter
ein splitter hat unser haus getroffen in
meine oma hat rim
sind doch alle am leben oder nicht
kurze zeit später stellt sich heraus
katjas familie ist am leben
erleichterung verdrängt langsam die
panik und angst
die psychologin erlebt häufig solche
grenzsituationen die meisten kinder im
kriegsgebiet im don was sind
traumatisiert dagegen will sie etwas tun
diese kinder brav ich möchte etwas gutes
tun und meinen eigenen einfluss auf die
situation haben ich will kein opfer der
entwicklung sein und ohnmächtig sein
katharina und ihr team wollen weitere
kinder der gegend besuchen vorbei an
einem zerstörten kraftwerk nach einem
artilleriebeschuss plötzlich schüsse der
reifen platzt war ganz schnell
michael unsere reifen
war du kannst hier nicht anhalten fahr
schüsse auch in der stand schnell sucht
den eingang ins haus verlieren
katharina und ihr team müssen schnell in
sicherheit
[Musik]
wenig später das gefecht ist vorbei
reifenwechsel
am telefon erfährt katharina dass es in
robert k wie der beschüsse gibt für die
kinder wird es immer gefährlicher
die familien flehen die psychologin an
ihre kinder aus dem kriegsgebiet
rauszuholen
am abend sammeln sie die kinder ein nur
weg von der front es geht nun weiter
nachhaken es ist der tag vor dem
russischen angriff auf die ukraine die
armee fahrzeuge unterwegs verheißen
nichts gutes
angekommen in der stadt eine
therapiestunde die an der front nicht
möglich war künstlerische frust und
angstbewältigung
erinnert euch jetzt an eure angst an der
front erinnert euch wie wahnsinnig euch
diese situation macht nun könnt ihr eure
ganze wut hieraus lassen
[Musik]
sie werden bluten ich mache das hier mit
dem das hier ist putin er lacht über uns
über unser leid
wonach ist es die ja mit ihm würde ich
das hier machen
lasst uns zusammen kann verbeugt euch
bitte wir sind mit euch zusammen andere
menschen lassen euch nicht im stich am
24 februar beginnt die russische
invasion in die ukraine die kinder legen
gerade in den betten als der krieg sie
auch hier erreicht die stadtrats steht
unter raketenbeschuss die psychologin
und ihr team beschließen die front
kinder sofort richtung westen an die
polnische grenze zu bringen mehr als
1000 kilometer liegen vor ihnen die
kinder wissen ihre familien bleiben
zuhause mitten im krieg
habe keine angst
nach vier tagen zu ende fahrt endlich
ankunft in den karpaten nahe der
polnischen grenze hier sind die
kriegskinder auf dem don was in einem
flüchtlingsheim untergebracht erstmal in
sicherheit
[Musik]